mein gott was verkehr man schon alles
gemacht er war personenschützer er hat
bei google gearbeitet und er ist ein
erfolgreicher let's player und er konnte
pixum und zwar am sonntag um 10 uhr wenn
er zufällig da seid auf der gamescom in
der speakers corner
in zusammenarbeit mit dem westdeutschen
rundfunk und er wird mir rede und
antwort stehen und er wird auch euch
rede und antwort stehen wenn ihr eure
fragen in die kommentare schreibt oder
als video antwort eurem video fragen
hochladen anfangs kommentarfeld klicken
dann eben dann an button
da kann man drauf klicken und einem
video antwort eurovideo frage als video
antwort hochladen und wenn er dann
vorher noch den info text gelesen habt
und auf die links dort auch geklickt
habt und kreativ sei dann kommt ihr auch
mit ziemlich großer sicherheit dran
ansonsten